suite à une rupture de canalisation mois
de février aux intempéries du mois de
juin les terrains des peupliers ne sont
plus que l'ombre d'eux mêmes ce qui pose
problème à de nombreuses associations et
écoles ça pénalise nos associations
sportives notamment le rugby le foot
c'est et puis les squares parce que
toutes nos installations sont occupés la
journée par les scolaires que ce soit
collèges lycées les écoles élémentaires
et bien sûr le soir le relais est pris
par les associations sportives et pour
réhabiliter les terrains des peupliers
la mairie a prévu deux grands chantiers
une première phase c'est la
stabilisation de ses terrains et puis
l'amélioration de tout le réseau
hydraulique
au tour donc avec la création
l'élargissement des bassins de rétention
nous qui existent et la création d'un
deuxième bassin
le drainage qui doit se faire aussi en
aval de ce ces bassins et puis la
deuxième phase dans l'ours à cette
première phase va se terminer au mois de
décembre et la deuxième phase
interviendra à partir du mois de juin et
la cie la réhabilitation vraiment la
reconstruction des terrains ces deux
grands chantiers ont pour but de
renforcer le système hydraulique pour
résister à l'avenir aux intempéries les
terrains des peupliers seront de nouveau
utilisable avant la rentrée de septembre